Y
SAYS SALUTE BILLIONS AND GAZA
HAVE BEEN KILLED BY THE ISRAELI
AIRSTRIKES.
FOR THE PAST, WEEKEND IN
-YEAR-OLD GIRL LIVING IN GAZA
HAS DOCUMENTED HER EXPERIENCE
ON SOCIAL MEDIA HERE IS ARWA
DAMON WITH HER STORY.
>> IT'S THE JUXTAPOSITION THAT
IS PERHAPS THE MOST JARRING.
BETWEEN THE CLIPS AND A SPRING
INFLUENCER USED TO POST ABOUT
HER LIFE.
FEATURING HER YOUNGER BROTHER.
THE CLIP THAT WAS POSTED OF HER
THAT WENT VIRAL.
>> I'M ALWAYS SICK.
I DON'T KNOW.
WOULD YOU EXPECT ME TO DO?
THE EXIT?
I'M ONLY 10.
I CAN'T EVEN DEAL WITH THIS.
I JUST WANT TO BE A DOCTOR OR
ANYTHING TO HELP MY PEOPLE.
BUT I CAN'T.
I'M JUST A KID!
>> SHE IS JUST A KID.
AT THE SAME TIME, SHE IS NOT,
NOT ANYMORE.
>> ARE YOU HAVING FUN?
LET'S GO.
IT'S OKAY, IT'S NOT NEAR US, I
PROMISE.
ANNA >> I WAS NOT LAUGHING
BECAUSE IT WAS FUNNY.
I WAS LAUGHING BECAUSE I WAS
TRYING TO KEEP MY BROTHER CALM
DOWN.
>> I LOVE YOU.
>> ME TOO.
>> BACK AGAIN HERE AND THIS IS
ALL THE STUFF WE GOT.
>> THIS IS WHAT THEY SHOULD
HAVE BEEN GETTING READY FOR.
INSTEAD, --
>> THIS IS MY BAG IN CASE
ANYTHING HAPPENS, OR OUR HOUSE
GETS EXPLODED.
I DON'T REALLY CARE ABOUT ANY
OF THOSE THINGS IN THE BAG, AS
I SAID.
I CARE ABOUT FAMILY.
I CARE ABOUT OTHER PEOPLE AND
THAT'S IT.
WHEN THE EXPLOSION HAPPENS, WE
ALL HANG OUT IN THIS ROOM.
IT'S BETTER TO DIE ALL OF US
TOGETHER.
THIS IS WHERE THE EXPLOSION IS
OUT.
YOU SEE THERE, THE AMBULANCE.
I THINK THAT'S A HOUSE.
>> OF COURSE NADIM GET SCARED,
HER MOTHER SAYS.
SHE COVERS HER FEAR FOR HER
BROTHER.
>> MORE POTATOES FOR ME.
THIS IS LIKE BREAKFAST DINNER.
>> NADINE MOTHER WATCHES HER
FAMILY AS IF SHE IS QUIETLY
RELISHING IN THE LAUGHTER OF
THE YOUNGER GENERATIONS.
FOR A LAUGHTER IS MORE PRECIOUS
IN TIMES LIKE THIS.
WHEN YOU KNOW EVEN IF YOU ARE
JUST A KID, THAT IT CAN AND AT